this on fox news alert moments ago
President Trump wrapping up yet another
massive rally this time in Broward
County Florida by the way and look at
this supporters stood in line all day
they get a spot inside this packed arena
which has a capacity of over 20,000 hmm
what Democrat can do this now prior to
the big rally Bill O'Reilly interviewed
the president on his radio show and bill
has given us an exclusive clip from that
one-on-one interview great question and
great answer by the president you want
to hear that and needless to say the
Democrats impeachment charade has only
solidified the president's base and is
now turning into an unmitigated
political disaster for the left remember
all last week while the media mob was
telling you trump has finished a
bombshell bombshell disaster disaster
well they were again lying to we the
people as they have been for three long
years for if you include the election
now according to multiple polls support
for impeachment among independents look
at this it is dropped dramatically in
the past several weeks look at this
Emerson poll double-digit swing among
independent independents as opposition
for impeachment is up whoa wiping 11
points meaning by by its people don't
like it Marquette University poll
concluding support for impeachment
dropped by four points in the swing
state the important state of Wisconsin a
political poll showed support for
impeachment is declining nationwide
interest in the impeachment charade has
even dipped among Democratic voters look
at your screen the 31 members of
Congress now representing those swing
districts pay close attention those
names right there that the president
carried in 2016 these guys are in full
panic mode and as Republican groups now
plan to plaster these districts with
multi-million dollar ad buys over the
Thanksgiving weekend you know when
footballs running et cetera so-called
moderate Democrats they're begging their
party leadership for help here's the
great irony though in all of this the
shift show ironically they actually
helped pay for
these ads as Americans showed they have
had enough from this compromised corrupt
congenital liar and they've been
donating record amounts of money to help
the President and help Republican
candidates he's paying for this thank
you I guess we have to say thank you to
the congenital liar one anonymous
Democratic lawmaker telling Politico
quote it's like someone taped our arms
to our side and punched us in the face
over the weekend Democratic lawmaker
from Michigan who once supported
impeachment now says she doesn't well
see the value in kicking Trump out of
office Wow oh wait this is a safe
district take a listen
you can censor you don't have to remove
the president so there's different
levels of activities that you can take
under the articles of impeachment we are
so close to an election I will tell you
sitting here knowing how divided this
country is I don't see the value of
taking him out of office
get this congresswoman Lawrence has
since recanted those remarks it is now
falling in line we can tell you why I
probably immense pressure from the
Democratic leadership the squad and yes
the compromised corrupt congenital liar
make no mistake this is not looking good
for the Democratic Party they're helping
the president win even the mob and the
media they're starting to take note look
at Jonathan Swan Axio said this has not
been encouraging from a democratic point
of view
look at this over there on the
conspiracy TV channel of area 51 raise
Rachel Maddow
yes Roswell Rachel MSDN sees Chuckie
Todd who by the way he's never going to
be anywhere near as great as the great
Tim Russert conceding that the shift'
show did not clear the political bar
then he made some other dumb analysis
about the legal bar but he doesn't know
what he's talking about was he listening
to his lunatic colleagues on the
conspiracy theory channel MSDN c1
Washington Post reporter said the polls
should be a very clear warning to the
Democrats take a look I do think that
this point is you
a sort of a warning sign for them I mean
if they're not able to move
public sentiment at all with those five
hearings with what is it like a dozen
State Department or NSC officials coming
it forward and testifying against the
president I mean that's a problem for
them I mean this should be a high point
for them in terms of making the case to
the voters and tonight it's not just the
polls on impeachment that should concern
the Democratic Party take a look at your
screen even in New York Times headline
that reads quote they voted Democratic
now they support Trump but they were
referring to his new data showing you
know Democrats that okay in the 2018
elections Donald Trump did not do
anywhere nearly as bad in the first well
midterm election as say Obama and
Clinton but anyway the two-thirds of the
battleground state voters who chose
Trump in 2016 but selected Democrats in
the midterms they're going back to Trump
in 2020
whoopsie-daisy if the New York Times
says it's two-thirds it's probably 98%
and meanwhile President Trump also
seeing a groundswell of support among
african-american voters these numbers
six separate polls are huge according to
this multiple new polls 16 to 34 percent
of African Americans and voters approve
of the president now keep in mind he
only garnered 8% of the african-american
vote in 2016 we will give you all the
analysis of why this is happening in
just a minute and also we'll be joined
by Ben Carson specifically will ask you
know how how the president how has he
helped minority communities in America
more in three years than the destructive
policies and by the way inordinately
impact in minority communities of Biden
and Obama those policies it's now
perfectly clear ukranian impeachment
this coup attempt is now a political
dumpster fire we you the American people
you're not buying the BS that Democrats
have been selling now for three long
years we've had enough and the wheels
are already in motion so today just as
we predicted the shift show is now
headed to the Jerry Nadler shift show in
the Judiciary Committee so
he can turn this flaming pile of garbage
and crap into an official impeachment
proceeding
good luck turning that hearsay he-said
she-said opinion and conjecture garbage
into something that even resembles
evidence the one witness that can
actually testify without offering
opinion or hearsay that one guy sunland
what the president actually said
remember he's on record saying you heard
the president said well what do you want
for Ukraine I want nothing no quid pro
quo that's not going to work out well in
the Senate when the rules of evidence
the Federal Rules of Evidence are
applied
of course nate'll will try his best and
the witch trial and the coup attempt
will continue remember in 1998 this is
the same Jerry Nadler that guy right
there railing against impeachment saying
it was an undoing of a national election
that votes were being ripped away from
the American people
neither didn't even want the Starr
report which the Independent Counsel
statute required be released to be
released maybe it's because it listed
eleven specific grounds for impeachment
including real felonies against this
fellow Democrat Bill Clinton remember
this mr. Starr and his transmitting
transmittal letter to the speaker and
the Minority Leader made it clear that
much of this material is Federal Rule 6
e material that is material that by law
unless contravened by a vote of the
house must be kept secret it's grand
jury material it represents statements
which may or may not be true by various
witnesses salacious material all kinds
of material that it would be unfair to
release noun Adler's got a spearhead and
impeachment proceeding against Donald
Trump now where there are no specific
grounds for impeachment whatsoever
remember Clinton lost his law license
paid a hell of a lot of money to Paula
Jones at the end of the day the level of
hypocrisy in the Democratic Party and
the mob and the media knows no bounds
now of course keep in mind this is all
much to do about nothing because the
Senate will never vote to convict and
instead will follow the federal rules of
evidence which means no hearsay will be
admitted and no opinion witnesses will
be heard it means nobody we heard from
in the ship show
this is very important president Trump
will finally be able to mount a defense
that's huge and earlier today he easily
just ripped apart the Democrats faulty
narrative during an interview with Bill
O'Reilly this is on his radio show take
a listen to this if you had to do the
phone call with the Ukraine president
again would you mention Joe Biden well I
was mentioned just as very unimportant
Lee and as you know Joe Biden's son
became rich as soon as Joe Biden became
vice president and in my way of thinking
that's totally corrupt we have to look
for corruption I mean we're sending them
tremendous amounts of money we don't
want to be sending it for corrupt
purposes and the other thing that
bothers me is why is in France and
Germany and you know NATO you could say
why are these other countries and and
institutions why aren't they paying some
of the money why is it always the sucker
United States BAM
president is on offense and at this
point Democrats don't even know if they
have the votes for impeachment those 31
well Democrats in Trump one districts
2016 they now face political peril the
president has withstood three plus years
the country has withstood three plus
years of what is an unprecedented
political onslaught no prior
administration no prior president has
ever faced this level of hatred rage
psychosis and vitriol and yet this
president has fought back every step of
the way including tonight during another
raucous fun rally this time in Florida